- [Instructor] The fifth century in Greece
started off with the Persian invasions,
and ended with the Peloponnesian War,
and now we're entering into
the fourth century in Greece.
And as we enter into the fourth century,
Thebes is the dominant city state,
but as we get into the mid fourth century,
and especially the end of it,
we will see that all of
Greece gets dominated,
and then unified, by the
Makedonians, or the Macedonians,
and in particular, the first unifier here
was Philip of Macedon.
This is a bust of him.
And he's known, as he
comes to power in 359 BCE,
he comes to power, his
father was king of Makedon,
but then his older
brothers die, he becomes,
it's actually his nephew
who is heir to the throne.
He becomes regent for his infant nephew,
which means that he has
the power temporarily,
but then he actually takes full control,
and becomes king of Macedon, or Makedon,
as it's often pronounced, in 359 BCE.
And what he then goes off about doing is
taking over most of the Greek city states.
And, eventually, he's able to unify
most of the Greek city states.
And you can see on this map here,
which I got from Wikipedia.
This is a little bit of
information about the map.
You can see how he expanded
his empire over time.
Remember, 359 BCE, he
becomes king of Macedon.
In 352, he's moving into Thessaly.
Then, in the 340s, he's going into Thrace.
So he's going into Thrace and Molossia.
And Molossia's interesting.
The king of Molossia, he
actually ends up marrying
the king of Molossia's daughter, Olympius,
who ends up being Alexander
the Great's mother.
And she's a pretty interesting character,
as we will see in a little bit.
She was part of this cult
that worshiped snakes.
It's believed that she slept with snakes.
But, he goes off and continues to conquer.
Eventually, he's able to subjugate
most of the city states of Greece,
except for Sparta.
And that takes us to 337, right over here,
where he's able to establish
the League of Corinth.
It was only called the League of Corinth
after the fact, but he gets the leaders
of the significant city
states together in Corinth.
That's why it's called
the League of Corinth,
and they swear their oath, essentially,
to Philip, king of Makedon,
who they call the Hegemon.
And what's really important about that
is he's able to unify
the Greek city states,
outside of Sparta,
and in doing so, he sets
things up for his son,
the famous Alexander the Great,
to continue to unify Greece.
Alexander the Great's actually
able to subjugate Sparta.
But then, more famously,
he goes off to conquer
the entire Persian
Empire, and then beyond,
in his short life.
And we'll have at least
another video on that.
But just to get a feel for what happened
at the League of Corinth in 337 BCE,
I will share this oath
that the variouscity
states had to commit to.
And it says, "I swear
by Zeus, Gaia, Helios,
"Poseidon, and all the gods and goddesses.
"I will abide by the common peace,
"and I will neither break
the agreement with Philip,
"nor take up arms on land or sea,
"harming any of those
abiding by the oaths.
"Nor shall I take any city or fortress,
"nor harbor by craft or contrivance,
"with intent of war against
the participants of the war.
"Nor shall I depose the kingship
"of Philip or his descendants,
"nor the constitutions
existing in each state,
"when they swore the oaths of the peace.
"Nor shall I do anything
contrary to these agreements,
"nor shall I allow anyone
else, as far as possible.
"But if anyone does commit
any breach of the treaty,
"I shall go in support as
called by those who need,
"and I shall fight the
transgressors of the common peace,
"as decided by the council,
and called on by the Hegemon."
Who is, when the oath is made,
who is Philip of Macedonia.
Now, unfortunately for
Philip, this happens in 337,
where, for the most part,
he's the first to unify
the Greek city states, outside of Sparta.
But he's only able to live
about a year after that.
A year later, we're now in 336 BCE,
and he's in the old capitol
of the Makedonian kingdom,
which is very close to Pella,
celebrating the wedding of his daughter
to his brother in law.
So his daughter, who
is Alexander's sister,
she's being married to Olympius's brother.
So he's marrying his
daughter to her uncle.
And it is during that wedding that
Philip of Macedon is killed by Pausanias,
who is his bodyguard.
And there's a lot of
really interesting stories.
So, he's killed at the wedding in 336 BCE,
and there's a lot of
really interesting stories
about what the motivation
for Pausanias was.
There are many accounts that say that
Pausanias was Philip's lover,
he was, on some level jealous,
and he was on some level because
another relative of Philip
affronted Pausanias,
and Philip didn't go to defend him.
There's some narratives that
this was arranged, somehow,
by Olympius, Philip's wife
and the mother of Alexander,
to put Alexander on the throne.
There're some motivations there because,
also, shortly before the assassination,
he took a second wife, which
was his more favored wife,
as opposed to Olympius.
So there's a lot of really
interesting accounts,
and I encourage you to read up on it.
But the interesting thing is,
is after he gets assassinated,
well, then there's a bit
of a scramble for power.
But it leaves Alexander the Great,
or eventually, Alexander
the Third officially,
but eventually Alexander the Great
becomes the Hegemon,
and he's eventually, in his short life,
he's only 20 years old
when he becomes king,
he's able to, as we'll see
in the next few videos,
take over all of the
Persian Empire and beyond,
and subjugate Sparta.
So he further unifies the Greeks,
and takes on the mighty Persian Empire.